now to our other top story here at five
o'clock the clark county school district
has postponed making a decision
on bringing kids back to school even
part-time eight news now reporter kate
houston spoke to teachers and students
to see how they feel about the change of
plans
students and teachers are weighing in as
the clark county school district delays
its decision on a hybrid learning plan
i think it's the best decision they can
make right now i'm happy i'm
relieved teacher jamie anderson tells me
she's not surprised given governor
sislek's suggestion to stay at home as
cases of covet 19
continue to climb i do think that there
needs to
be a little bit more time to see where
where things are going to be going over
the next couple of weeks before we make
any
any other determinations this now gives
the clark county school district time to
fine
tune its plan and make sure suggestions
from families and the board are being
heard
superintendent dr jesus jarrah says
there needs to be a standardized
curriculum across the district
right now students are getting it
through canvas and google meet
we don't have a specific date during a
meeting friday dr
jara says while there's no target date
to get students back in the classroom
he would like to bring the hybrid
learning plan back to the board in
december
in order to get everyone back in the
classroom though dr jarrah wants to see
a downward trend in covet 19 cases
adding the safety of families and
district employees is his top priority
kate houston 8 news now